[موسيقى]
وسط استمرار الاشتباكات بالمدفعيه الثقيله
في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم واتهامات متبادله بانتهاك الهدنه
الاخيره كما هو الحال في الهدن السابقه
اعلن الجيش السوداني تعليق مشاركته في
مفاوضات جده التي تجري برعايه امريكيه
وسعوديه متهما قوات الدعم السريع بعدم
تنفيذ اي من البرود التي تم الاتفاق عليها
في جده قرار اثار حفيظه الاداره الامريكيه
التي سارعت الى فرد حزمه من العقوبات
اقتصاديه على شركات تابعه لطرفي النزاع
مهدده باتخاذ المزيد من الاجراءات
العقابيه ما لم يحترم الطرفان التزاماتهما
بوقف اطلاق النار والعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات فالى اين تمضي الازمه السودانيه
المتفاقمه في ظل قرار الجيش تعليق مشاركته
في مفاوضات جدا والرد الامريكي على ذلك
ولماذا تبدو الازمه في السودان حتى الان
عصيه على الحل رغم تعدد المبادرات
الاقليميه والدوليه وكثره الهدن اهلا بكم
في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم بوتيره سريعه تتحرك عجله
الازمه السودانيه نحو مزيد من التفاقم
والتعقيد خاصه بعد تطورات الاخيره التي
دفعت الاداره الامريكيه الى الاعلان عن
عقوبات تستهدف العصب الاقتصادي والتصنيعي
لكلا طرفي النزاع عن قرار تعليق المشاركه
في مفاوضات جده وتداعياته على مسار
التسويه خاصه بعد اعلان العقوبه الامريكيه
على طرفي الصراع يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه في الاستوديو الدكتور عبد
الفتاح محمد الباحث الزائر في مركز دراسات
النزاع والعمل الانساني من الدوحه الدكتور
اسامه عيدروس محلل للشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه السودانيه ومن اديس ابا الدكتور
بروك هايلو استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه اديس فاهلا
بهم جميعا
في الوقت الذي تواجه فيه محادثات وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان خطر الانهيار بعد
قرار الجيش تعليق مشاركته في مفاوضات جده
فرضت الولايات المتحده قيودا على
التاشيرات تشمل مسؤولين من الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع كما فرضت عقوبات على شركات
مرتبطه بها او بهما بالاحرى اتهمتها
بتاجيج الصراع في السودان وقد قالت وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه في بيان لها انها
استهدفت شركتين تابعتين للجيش السوداني
وشركتين تابعتين لقوات الدعم السريع متهمه
اياها بتحقيق ايرادات من الصراع والمساهمه
في تغذيته فقد فرضت واشنطن عقوبات على
شركه الجنيد لتعدين الذهب التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع وشركه تريد ايف للتجاره
العامه التي تستخدمها الدعم السريع بشراء
معدات لقواتها
كما فرضت عقوبات على شركه سودان ماستر
تكنولوجي التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه
السودانيه لدورها في دعم شركات انتاج
اسلحه ومركبات للجيش واوضحت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه جانت ان الهدف من هذه العقوبات
وقطع التدفقات الماليه الرئيسيه الى طرفي
النزاع وحرمانهما من الموارد اللازمه
لمواصله الحرب في السودان وقبل اعلان فرض
هذه العقوبات قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكل ان الطرفين انتهى
التزاماتهما بوقف اطلاق النار واضاف ان
واشنطن ستواصل الانخراط مع الاطراف للعمل
من اجل مساعده انسانيه دون عوائق واسكات
البنادق واستعاده الامن والاستقرار في
السودان حسب تعبيره
هذه العقوبات والقيود على التاشيرات تمثل
اول اجراء عقابيه فرضه بموجب امر تنفيذي
وقعه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الشهر
الماضي وتاتي هذه العقوبات وسط مخاوفه
وتحذيرات امميه ومريكيه من صراعا طويل
الامد في حال استمرار طرفي النزاع في خرق
الهدن المتفق عليها ووسط مساعي جديده من
الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه السودانيه
هدنه تلو الهدنه لكن هذا بقي المشهد
المالوف في العاصمه السودانيه
تحجب سحب الحرب رؤيه اي افق لوقف القتال
ازداد الوضع تعقيدا بعدما اعلن الجيش
تعليق مشاركته في محادثات جده احتجاجا على
ما قال انها خروق متكرره للهدنه من جانب
قوات الدعم السريع يتهمها الجيش بانها لم
تلتزم باخلاء المستشفيات ومرافق الخدمات
كما قضى بذلك اتفاق الهدنه الاخيره وضع
قرار الجيش الوسطاء امام تحد جديد اصبحت
اولويتهم الان ابقاء الطرفين على طاوله
التفاوض وتجنب انهيار كامل للمحادثات حتى
وان لم تفضي في المدى القصير الى وقف كامل
لاطلاق النار على الارض يدير الطرفان
المعركه النفسيه كما تدار المعارك
بالاسلحه فظهور القائد العام للجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان في مقطع فيديو هدد فيه
باستخدام القوه المميته في بعدم صياع
الدعم السريع الى صوت العقل وفق تعبيره
قابله ظهور القائد الثاني للدعم السريع
عبد الرحيم دقلو وهو يدعو افراد الجيش الى
الخروج عن البرهان والتنسيق مع قواته قد
يخشى من تهديد البرهان باستخدام القوه
المميته ان يتخلى الجيش عن محاذير استهداف
قوات الدعم السريع المتمدرسه وسط المناطق
الماهوله في الخرطوم ما قد يجعل حصيله
الضحايا من المدنيين اثقل رغم ان المتحدث
باسم الجيش اكد ان مقاله البرهان جاءت في
سياق التحذير ليس الا
وبتعليق الجيش مشاركته في محادثه جده
تتعلق امال الوسطاء الان بمبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي المعلنه اواخر شهر ايار مايو
منقضي تتضمن المبادره تاسيس اليه تنسيق
لضمان تناغم جهود الفاعلين الاقليميين
والدوليين وتحقيق وقف فوري ودائم للقتال
الى جانب اطلاق عمليه سلام واحده وشامله
وتسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
الممرات الجويه والبريه والبحريه ومنع
التدخل الخارجي يراد لمبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي ان تجنب السودان تعدد المبادرات
والمنصات وتراعي بلا شك ان المخاطر
المحدقه بدول جوار السودان بسبب استمرار
الصراع والازمه الانسانيه الناتجه عنه
لكنها لا تتضمن اي اجراءات ردع في حال
انتهاك الطرفين او احدهما لاي اتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار فهل ستحقق خريطه
الطريق الافريقيه الاختراق الذي لم تحدثه
مفاوضات جده قبلها
دكتور عبد الفتاح محمد اهلا وسهلا بك هذه
العقوبات الامريكيه التي فرضت على طرفي
النزاع في السودان ما الذي يمكن ان تغيره
عمليا
العقوبات الامريكيه يمكن ان تكون رساله
تحذيريه
للطرفين على ان الاستمرار في النزاع لن
يكون يعني
لن يتم السكوت عنه ولكن تاثير العقوبات قد
لا يكون بشكل كبير
لحمل الطرفين على الرجوع مره اخرى الى
طاوله المفاوضات
وهدنه جده مجددا الامر الاخر
في اعتقادي انه قد لا يوجد حسابات تحمل
اموال طائله في جعبه الطرفين كي يكون لهذا
الامر تاثير الكبير او التاثير الذي يؤثر
على
عوده الطرفين مره اخرى الى المفاوضات او
الى وقف اطلاق النار لان الذي يظهر
بالنسبه للطرفين انهما ليسوا اصحاب شركات
او اصحاب مؤسسات هم جاؤوا الى الحكم في
خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
وربما قد يكون هناك بعض الاموال التي قد
يستفاد منها باعتبار انه دائما للنزاعي
نوع من الاقتصاد كما يسمى نزاع الاقتصاد
وهو ان يتم الصرف من خلال ما يحصل من
اموال من بعض الحسابات على ان ايضا
البرهان كان قد جمد حسابات لقوه الدعم
السريع تقريبا قبل اسبوعين يعني
وقام ببعض الاجراءات لكني لا اعتقد انه
هذا الاجراء التحذيري سيكون كافيا لحمل
الفريقين مره اخرى الى يعني وقف اطلاق
النار ولكن الاداره الامريكيه هددت
بالمزيد ما الذي يمكن ان تضيفه اذا ما
تمادى الطرفان في عاده الاداره الامريكيه
تقوم بمنع السفر على سبيل المثال كاحد
يعني جزء من حزم العقوبات
قضيه اللي هو يعني منع السفر لكن في في
ظروف
التاشيره التاشيره لكن لا احد اعتقد في
حساباته لان ان يذهب الى امريكا او كذا
يعني فبالتالي ماذا يمكن ان تكون يعني
الحزم الاقوى من العقوبات بالنسبه لهذه
الفريقين انا اعتقد ان الاقتصار على
العقوبات لن يكون حلا مفيدا لحمل الطرفين
للرضوخ او للاستماع بشكل افضل الى الرساله
الامريكيه وتنفيذ ما ينبض ما ينبغي تنفيذه
للمضي قدما نحو واقع جديد في السودان اذا
اردنا ان نعرف تاثير هذه العقوبات دكتور
اسامه عيدروس على طرفي النزاع مثلا
بالنسبه للجيش هذه العقوبات التي
اتخذت فيما يتعلق بالتصنيع العسكري للجيش
هل فعلا يمكن ان تؤثر
حقيقه يعني الغرار غريب جدا
للجيش وللدعم السريع يعني الاسماء التي
وردت في قائمه العقوبات يعني هي اسماء
ربما تكون ما زالت مسجله
كشركات او كاسماء عمل لكن هي ليست موجوده
على الارض يعني
منظومه الصناعات الدفاعيه اسم قديم جدا
صاحب انشاء منظومه الصناعات العسكريه
للجيش منذ بدايته
لكنها تم تفكيكها منذ زمن بعيد يعني اصبحت
مجرد لافته
داخلها العديد من يعني شركات اخرى كبيره
جدا
كثيره مسجله هي التي تخدم الجيش في عمليات
التصنيع الحربي وغيره وحتى اسم ماستر
تكنولوجي ليس هنالك الشركه على الارض يعني
ربما يكون اسم مسجل لكن ليس هنالك شركه
على الارض نفس الشيء بالنسبه
للجنيد الجنيد تم تفكيكها منذ زمن هي ما
زالت مسجله كشركه لكن اعمال الدعم السريع
يعني
[موسيقى]
الاموال وحركتها وكل شيء يتحرك عبر عبر
منافذ اخرى كثيره وشركات والشركات مملوكه
لافراد لا يمكن حتى حصرها او عدها هذا
سببه الاساسي
السودان اصلا
تحزمه قاسيه من العقوبات الامريكيه
بدات يعني دخل السودان في رادار العقوبات
الامريكيه منذ عهد الديمقراطيه الثالثه
عام 1988
وخلال السنوات الماضيه تم تنفيذ يعني اقصى
حزمه عقوبات يمكن ان تنفذ على دوله يمكن
اقصى من حزمه العقوبات المفروضه على كوريا
الشماليه او ايران
ولكن ولكن هذه العقوبات سيدي عيدروس رفعت
بعد ذلك
رفعت بعد ذلك ولكن مثلا يعني بالنسبه
للدعم السريع مثلا مصدر مطلع في الجيش
السوداني صرح للجزيره بان الجيش لن يتضرر
كثيرا ولكن ما سماها الامبراطوريه الماليه
لعائله حميدتي هي التي ستتاثر بفعل هذه
العقوبات هل هذا صحيح
عسى مباشره ربما الشركه الموجوده في
الامارات ربما هي التي تقوم بشراء المباشر
لمشتريات الدعم السريع لكن هل يؤثر ذلك
على المعركه الحاليه هذه المعركه تم
التجهيز لها منذ اربع سنوات
وكل التجهيزات الان موجوده على الارض ليس
من تجهيزات جديده يمكن ان تضاف الى ما هو
موجود فعلا انا اظن انه الاداره الامريكيه
ترى الوضع على الارض والتقارير على الارض
وتريد ان تقول للناس انها تفعل شيئا ولا
تخاطب قضيه الصراع بشكل مباشر وشكل اساسي
ينهي الصراع ويوقف معاناه السودانيه هي لا
تسهم في ايقاف الصراع هذه العقوبات ستطيل
امد الصراع ولن تسهم في شيء ولكن هل هذه
العقوبات الدكتور هيلو في ادي سببا هل
يمكن ان يكون لها
دلاله سياسيه بمعنى اذا لم تتحركوا بسرعه
فان واشنطن قد تذهب الى ما هو اقصى من ذلك
وبالتالي قد يكون هذا تحذير مثل ما قال
ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو للعوده الى
المفاوضات بالدرجه الاولى
حسنا شكرا السيد محمد استضافته في برنامجك
وايضا تحياتي لكم من اديس ابابا وايضا
للضيفين الكريمين
نعم استطيع القول نعم هذه العقوبات هي
رساله تحذيريه من الحكومه الامريكيه وهي
لن تتوقف بل ستستمر طبعا تاثير هذه
العقوبات لا يمكن الشعور بها مباشره لان
القوتين السياسيتين وقوه الجيش وقوه الدعم
السريع غادي يكون لديهم اموال نقديه وذهب
ولكن هذا المال هو الذهب سينفذ بمرور
الوقت بسبب القتال الشديد فهم يحتاجون الى
الذخيره والمواد والمشتريات كثيره
وبالتالي فهذه هذا سيكون عليه الحال وطبعا
الحكومه الامريكيه كما يبدو قد قررت الان
ان
بالسلسله من العقوبات وهذا
ستستمر وهذا يشبه
عصره
الروابط الاقتصاديه لهذين المجموعتين
السياسين اما بالنسبه للتاثيرات والتبعات
السياسيه فهذا دعم تحذير لمن يدعمهما فنعل
الناس ان هذين السيدين لديهم سلسله قياده
والسلسله مجموعات مصالح اقتصاديه يدوران
حول الجنرال اذا
وبالتالي فالامر لن يعتصر عليهما بل سيصل
الجذورهم وهذا هو الهدف وبالتالي هنا في
هذا الوقت من الزمن ما استطيع قوله هو ان
العقوبات جربت في عدد من الدول كما قال
احد الضيفين باشكال مختلفه اقتصاديه
ودبلوماسيه وسياسيه
وتقييد الحركه البدنيه
لممثلي الحكومه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع وكل هذه الاشكال من العقوبات يمكن
بدء بها واطلاقه واحده بعد الاخرى هذا
مصنع قوله حاليا
ولكن اذا اخذنا الهدف الاقرب على الاقل
الدكتور عبد الفتاح محمد وهو حث الطرفين
على العوده الى
مباحثات جدا هل هذه العقوبات
ستعجل مثلا مراجعه الجيش لقراره في
اعتقادي ان
الطرفين دخلا الهدنه بحسابات
وايضا تعليق الجيش
لعدم الدخول في الهدنه مره اخرى حتما سوف
يكون لحسابات معينه ربما يشعر الجيش ان
ساعه الحسم قد اقتربت
فيريد ان يعني يستمر في في هذه المواجهه
العسكريه
وربما تكون هذه الحسابات مبنيه على
معلومات استخباراتيه او غيرها واكثر من
مراقب يتكلم عن سيناريو الحسم من قبل
الجيش الامر الاخر انه يريد ان يعني يرفع
الغطاء الاخلاقي عن الطرف الاخر بمعنى
الجيش يريد ان يرفع الغطاء الاخلاقي عن
الطرف الاخر
ويتهمه بما ارتكب من استخدام لاماكن معينه
بما يخالف البنود المذكوره في اعلان جده
كل هذه قضايا حسابات بمعنى ان هناك حساب
من هذا الطرف من هذا الطرف الان اتت
العقوبات الامريكيه ورسالتها التحذيريه
التي تريد ان تحمل الطرفين الى العوده مره
اخرى ولكن عفوا اذا اخذنا ما وصفت انت
بسيناريو الحسم ربما عندما نعود الى ما
استعمله البرهان الجيش لم يستعمل بعد
القوه القوه المميته وانسحاب من محادثات
جده قد تعني انه ربما قرر في النهايه ان
ربما حتى الذهاب الى جده كان خطا لانه
وضعه في منزله تقريبا مساويه مساويه مش
تقريبا منزله مساويه
لقوات الدعم لخصمه نعم اذا في هذه الحاله
العقوبات مع اقتراب سيناريو الحسم لن
تساهم في العوده بالضروره نعم لن تساهم في
العوده ولن تساهم في ان يفكر الجيش مره
اخرى في
ان ان العوده للمفاوضات وان العوده لوقف
اطلاق النار انه قد يحل المشكله الامر
الاخر ميدانيا ما دام قد جرت يعني
اختراقات لهذه الخروقات لهذه الهدنه فما
الداعي ان يعني ياتي يذهب مره اخرى الجيش
الى الهدنه في الوقت الذي يتم فيها خروقات
من قبل الطرف الاخر الذي هو خصمه اللي قوه
الدعم السريع موضوع العقوبات فيها موضوع
قطعه تدفقات الماليه وفي كذا مره يقع
الاشاره الى منع التدخل الخارجي هل يمكن
ان يفهم بانه التدفقات الماليه ليست
بالضروره داخليه وانما ايضا اقليميه
ودوليه قد تكون هل هل يمكن ان نفهم ذلك
يمكن يمكن ان نفهم هذا وبخاصه انه في حاله
الصراعات وفي حاله النزاعات قد يمر يعني
قد يتم تمرير ال ال
الاموال باشكال مختلفه باشكال نقديه
وباشكال كثيره ليس بالضروره عن طريق
العمليات البنكيه
[موسيقى]
وبهذا يت موقف
الصراع ويصبح هناك من يستفيد من هذا
الصراع بل من يجعل من هذا الصراع كما
يقولون اقتصادا كاملا قائما بحد ذاته
وراينا هذا في الكثير من دول النزاعات نعم
الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه الدكتور
عيدروس اكيد اصيبت بنكسه جراء هذا
الانسحاب الجيش من محادثات جده هل تعتقد
بانه يمكن ان يعود بشروط معينه او في ظروف
معينه
عندما بدات مفاوضات جده الحرب نفسها وصلت
الى مرحله معينه اللي هي انتهت الحرب في
الولايات او توقفت بعد استسلام ست معسكرات
للدعم السريع في الولايات وانتهاء المعارك
في مطار مروي وانتقلت المعركه الى الخرطوم
معركه الخرطوم هي معركه
دخول قوات الدعم السريع الى بيوت
المواطنين والى المرافق الحيويه والى
المستشفيات حتى اليوم 34 مستشفى داخل
الخرطوم تحولت الى ثكنه عسكريه قاعده
عسكريه عملياتيه بالنسبه للدعم السريع
هذا الامر يعني الدخول الى مفاوضات جده
كان الغرض منه كسر حده
النزاع والصراع ثم التفاوض مرحله بعد
مرحله يعني الوصول الى خطوه والبناء عليها
الوصول الى خطوه والبناء عليها بالنسبه
للجيش حدد السقف انه يريد ترتيبات
امنيه تضمن سلامه المدنيين وخروج الدعم
السريع من المرافق الحيويه ومن بيوت
المواطنين
الخطوه الاولى مضت باتفاق مبادئ ثم تم
مناقشه الهدنه لسبع ايام دون تحديد كيفيه
خروج الدعم السريع من المرافق وبيوت
المواطنين التي يحتلها
وكان من المفترض ان تكون الخطوه الثالثه
البناء على الاتفاقيه الثانيه والهدنه
الثانيه في بناء اليه واضحه لهذا الخروج
من بيوت المواطنين الذي حدث انه اتسعت
عمليات احتلال منازل المواطنين
بعضهم منها وتحويلها الى ميدان قتال في
انتظار هجوم الجيش الاخير باعتبار انه كل
الاهداف العسكريه للدعم السريع فشلت في
هجومه على المعسكرات الصغيره والكبيره
فشلت المفاوضات في ان تضع اليه واضحه يعني
هذه كانت فرصه فعليه لانهاء النزاع ان
يخرج الدعم السريع الى
اماكن
امنه بحيث لا يكون تحت نيران الجيش ولكن
ايضا لا يستطيع ان يطور عملياته في
المستقبل تحت مراقبه دوليه اذا حدث هذا
الامر ستنتهي الحرب فعليا لانه هذه الحرب
هي حرب الخرطوم الان ليست حرب اهليه ليست
حرب سياسيه ليست حرب مطلبيه هي حرب
الخرطوم ولكن المشكله الدكتور عيدروس ان
كل طرف يطمع في حسم عسكري ينهي به
الصراع في الخرطوم اساسا ولكن اذا نظرنا
الى ما يجري الان دكتور هيلو في ادي سببا
كانت هناك
اجتماعات الاربعاء الاليه الموسعه للنظر
شارك فيها الجامعه العربيه الامم المتحده
للاتحاد الافريقي الاتحاد الاوروبي وغيرها
من الدول عندما تفرض العقوبات الامريكيه
الان وينسحب الجيش من محادثات جده هل هذه
ضربه لهذه المساعي التي انطلقت الان من
ادي سببا الاربعاء
شكرا قبل ان اجيب على ذلك ارجو ان اضيف
نقطه الى هذا النقاش
وهي ان ما يحصل في السودان هو ان هذه
الحرب تجري في الواقع ضد قانون الدولي
وضد كل قواعد الاشتباك في الحروب
قتال بين بين منزل لشارك المدنيين
الضالعون فيه ومتورطون
وكل قواعد الاشتباكات قد كسرت وهذا حقيقه
محزنه والنقطه اخرى وضع عرضها وهي انه
عندما
القيادات يقاتلون فيه وهم مرتاحين في
معسكرتهم وفي غرفهم ولكن ما الذي يموت
الذي يموت هو جندي السوداني الاعتيادي او
النساء التي يقتلنا ويغتصبنا
اموالهم وممتلكاتهم هؤلاء هم الضحايا
والقتلهم من الجنود والجنود من الجانبين
والجنود هم ليس نخبه الناس بل المواطنين
العاديين وهذه حقيقه محزنه هذا امر لا بد
من التاكيد عليهم اما فيما يتعلق مبادره
جديد للجنه الدوليه فما لدينا هو اربعه
عناصر
واربعه اطراف مهمين هم الاتحاد الافريقي
والجامعه العربيه
وايجاد
المتحده واعتقد
ان هذا سبب هذا يمكنك في هذا المسعد
امكانيه نجاح كبيره فهذه المبارده يقودها
مجلس الامن والسلام في الاتحاد الافريقي
منظمه اقليميه مشاركه وما لدينا هنا جميع
الدول السبعه المجاوره
مجاوره للسودان ايضا مضلع ومشاركه كم بصفه
مراقب وايضا هناك اصحاب علاقه مثل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ممارات العربيه المتحده
وقطر والى غيرهم وبالتالي اعتقد هذا كله
سوف يكون مؤثرا وسيجذب يجذب امكانيه
سودانيه من قبل دول المجاوره والاقليميه
والدول والمنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه وامم
المتحده واعتقد هذا سيضع ضغوطا على كل
المجموعتين المتقاتلتين في السودان لابد
ان يعودا الى الحوار لا من اجل السودان ان
يعودا ويضع
اسبابهم الشخصيه مهما كانت يضعوا تحت ولا
وما يضعونه فوق واهم شيء هو مصلحه السودان
السودان مثل 990 يحصلوا بالسلامه فالشعب
السوداني كما هو حال كل شعوب العالم في
افريقيا هو الشرق الاوسط
بسلام والازدهار بالسلام وان يتوجه الى
الاطفال الى مدارسهم بسلام لكن ما يحصل
حاليا او ان هؤلاء الجنرانين يقاتلون
بعضهما الاخر ولا اعتقد انهم يضعون مصلحه
القوميه للسودان امامهم بل هم يضعون
امامهم
مصالحهم الشخصيه فقط وبالتالي على السؤال
دان ان تحضر مساعده الجميع وهنا اعتقد ان
الحل الاكبر فيها مثل هذه اللجنه الدوليه
هو المجتمع المدني السوداني لابد ان يشارك
وكما تعلم السيد محمد في 2020 عندما
عندما انتهى حكم البشير الذي كان بقيت 30
سنه تحت بصفاظ المقاومه الشعب السوداني
كان هناك امل لدى الشعب السوداني ان يجد
اخيرا
منظومه او نظام
ديمقراطيا مدنيا تتمتع بحريه الصحافه
والقضاء المستقر ولكن ما حصل في السنوات
الماضيه هو من اي من هذه الاعمال لم يتحقق
لم يتحقق وايضا الى نقطه مهمه بعد اذنك
سيد هيلو وهي التكلفه الانسانيه والمديه
لهذا الصراع تكلفه غير مسبوقه باهظه جدا
نتعرف على بعض اوجهها
[موسيقى]
اوقعت الحرب المستعره بين طرفي النزاع حتى
الان اكثر من 1800 قتيل معظمهم من
المدنيين وفقا لمنظمه اكليد غير الحكوميه
وتفيد احصاءات الامم المتحده ان نحو مليون
ونصف مليون شخص اجبروا على الفرار من
ديارهم
وتعتبر فئه الاطفال الاكثر تضررا فقد
اعلنت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
اليونيسف ان اكثر من 13 مليونا
سوداني بحاجه ماسه الى الدعم الانساني
واشارت الى ان هذا العدد هو اعلى رقم مسجل
على الاطلاق في البلاد وان وضع الاطفال
السودانيين بلغ مستويات كارثيه في ظل
استمرار القتال كما ان اكثر من 65% من
سكان السودان يرزحون تحت خط الفقر فهناك
نحو 25 مليون من اصل خمسه واربعين مليون
سوداني بحاجه الى مساعدات انسانيه
للاستمرار على قيد الحياه
واكدت الامم المتحده ان سكان السودان من
بين الاكثر حاجه في العالم في الوقت
الحالي الى اهتمام عاجل لتفاد انعدام
الامن الغذائي
ويستضيف السودان اكثر من مليون واشار
تقرير للامم المتحده الى ان من المرجح ان
يعود مئات الالاف الى بلدانهم في حال
استمرار الصراع وحذر التقرير من ان الصراع
على طرفي النزاع في السودان ستكون له على
الارجح تداعيات كبيره على الدول المجاوره
هذه التداعيات الكبيره على الدول المجاوره
الدكتور عبد الفتاح محمد يعني اشار الى
بعضها على الاقل ذكر اثيوبيا جنوب السودان
تشاد هناك الان خوف من امكانيه امتداد
الصرال هل تعتقد بان هذا وارد
النزاعات في افريقيا راينا فيها
يعني حالات مشابهه لمعنى بمجرد ان يندلع
نزاع معين
يحدث هناك حاله نزوح وكذلك تحدث حاله لجوء
والارقام الان مهوله ولا ننسى ان الجوار
جوار السودان يعني فيه دول تعاني من
نزاعات يعني اثيوبيا خرجت من نزاع مؤخرا
وكان نزاعا مريرا
ليبيا في وضع غير مستقر حتى هذه اللحظه
تشاد ليست بعيده ايضا عن عن السودان وكذلك
افريقيا الوسطى ليست بعيده فانت تتحدث عن
منطقه واسعه جدا ويمكن اذا حدث يعني اذا
استمر هذا النزاع بهذا المستوى من التعقيد
ان تتفاقم ازمه اللجوء فتهدد حتى حدود
اوروبا يعني تصل الى طبعا وصل اللاجئون
الى مصر ووصلوا الى تشاد الى اثيوبيا
واريتريا وجنوب السودان وهذه الدول وصلوا
الى ليبيا من هناك نعم من هناك او الى
تونس او الى غير الى دول اخرى
والوضع العالمي بشكل عام فيما يتعلق
بالناحيه الاقتصاديه ليس في احسن احواله
فمن سيقدم المعونه والمساعده لهؤلاء
اللاجئون في وقت ايضا حاله النزوح في
السودان لم تبدا مع اندلاع النزاع كان
هناك نازحون وكان هناك ايضا لاجئون في
السودان السودان يعتبر بلد يستقبل لاجئين
منذ عشرات عشرات السنين
والتحديات الخاصه بقضيه اللجوء الان
والنزوح انها تحديات للاطفال لان اعداد
كبيره من هؤلاء اللاجئين والناجحين هم
اطفال ونساء وهذا يجعل القضيه معقده من
سيقدم لهم المساعده والمعونه ولذلك لا بد
من تداعي للمجتمع الدولي والمجتمع
الاقليمي المانحين واحب ان اشيد هنا بدوله
قطر ودورها على الصعيد الانساني وتقديمها
للمساعدات باعتبار تجربتها السابقه دوله
قطر فيما يتعلق بتقديم المساعدات وبخاصه
المنظمات الانسانيه ودورها الدبلوماسيه
الانسانيه في ايصال المساعده بالنسبه
للتسويه عندما اجتمع اجتمعت هذه الدول في
اديس الاربعاء تحدثت عن خريطه الطريق صحيح
ملامحها غير واضحه تماما حديث فقط عن
العوده الى العمليه السياسيه لكن هل الان
الوضع اصعب بكثير من السابق ليس فقط بسبب
توقف محادثات جدا بسبب العقوبات الامريكيه
بسبب التصريحات البرهان الاخيره
وربما ايضا بسبب عدم القدره على
اجتراح اي تسويه وعندما نعرف ان المبعوث
الاممي بوكر
غير مرغوب فيه من قبل البرهان كل هذا كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر على طبخ هذه التسويه انصح
التعبير هو سوف تكون حتما طبخه معقده لان
السودان لديه تاريخ من الاشكالات مع
مبعوثي او مسؤوليه الامم المتحده من يعني
منذ اندلاع صراع دارفور هناك اكثر من
مسؤول اممي تم طرده وابعاده من السودان او
تم رفضه ان يكون موجود في السودان
وغياب الامم المتحده في هذه المرحله سواء
للجانب السياسي او الجانب الانساني فيه
صعوبه ومع تعقد الوضع الانساني داخل
السودان المنظمات الانسانيه التابعه للامم
المتحده انسحبت ومؤخرا سمعنا انه
ما قدم من غذاء لبرنامج الغذاء من قبل
برنامج الغذاء العالمي تم
السيطره عليه وتم نهبه فلديك مشكله معقده
على كل الاصعده سواء الصعيد السياسي ومن
يمكن ان يدعم هذه المبادره الاخيره
لا شك انها غامضه لانها غير واضحه والامور
والامور ستزداد تعقيدا دكتور لان بيان
جديد
للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم بيان سعودي
امريكي مشترك يعلن تعليق محادثات جده يعني
بدانا الان في في رؤيه التداعيات يعني اذا
هل هذا سيؤدي في النهايه الى مزيد وهنا
اسمح لي انقل السؤال الى الدكتور عيدروس
في ضوء هذه التطورات المتلاحقه هل سنشهد
عوده ضاريه للمعارك الان في الخرطوم لان
الان لا حل امام اي من الطرفين سوى الحسم
العسكري
هذا يعني بالنسبه
للفضاء للفضاء الدولي وحتى المبادره
الافريقيه ذكرت هذا البند انه بند خروج من
المرافق خروج
الق الدعم السريع هي لم تشير الى الدعم
السريع ولكن تحدثت عن خروج من منازل
المدنيين
ومن المرافق الخدميه وغيرها هذه النقطه
الكل يهرب منها يعني للولايات المتحده
تريد ادانه واضحه للدعم السريع
لاحتلال لهذه البيوت المدنيين ولا نهبوا
للبنوك ولا احتلال للمستشفيات يعني من
البارحه وحتى اليوم اكثر من ست مرات هجموا
على البنك المركزي الاحتلالي يعني ما في
اهداف عسكريه تدمير واضح وانتهاكات يعني
كما ذكر الدكتور من اديس ابا انه ليس
هنالك اي مراعاه لقواعد الاشتباك في
القانون الدولي ولكن
اذا استمر هذا الوضع هل هناك اي امكانيه
لحسم عسكري لاين من الطرفين يعني اذا
ذهبنا في القوه المميته للجيش هل هو قادر
اعمالها والدعم السريع والدعم السريع هل
هو قادر على الحسم امام مؤسسه الجيش وهي
ليست بسيطه طبعا المعرفه ليست سهله يعني
من يتحدث عن معركه سهله يكون قد كذب على
الناس هذه معركه قويه جدا الدعم السريع في
وسط المدنيين لا بد من استراتيجيه تحمي كل
المدنيين معركه يتم فيها قطع اطراف الدعم
السريع وشل حركته وشل قدرته على استخدام
بيوت المواطنين
كمنطقه عسكريه وهذه مساله من الصعوبه
بمكان حرب المدن بها صعوبات لكن مع ذلك
الجيش اثبت انه يسير باستراتيجيه وبخطوات
محدده يتقدم كل يوم يعني حتى معارك الامس
واليوم كان فيها تقدم كبير جدا للجيش
تشيشي بانه يمتلك زمام الامور كان هنا
فرصه للمبادرات اذا توصلت الى خروج الدعم
السريع من الخرطوم ووضعه في معسكر خارجي
كان يمكن ان تنتهي هذه الحرب بسلام لكن
الان المعركه قادمه لابد من معركه حاسمه
تحسم هذه الامور ولكن هل معنى ذلك اذا
استمرت هذه الامور العسكريه دكتور هايلو
في ادي سببا وفي ضوء ما ذكرته انا قبل
قليل من ان محادثات جده علقت او او توقفت
يعني يعني السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
مثل ما ذكرت اعلنت تعليق
محادثات جدا بين الطرفين النزاع في
السودان هل معنى ذلك ان حتى خارطه الطريق
الغامضه التي اعلنت في ادي سببه ستنهار
لانه اذا كنا غير قادرين حتى على ضمان هدم
هدنه محدوده خمسه ايام او اسبوع فما بالك
بتسويه سياسيه
شكرا
بالعكس سيتحقق لان هذه المبادره
ينبغي اولا اختبارها
لان السيد محمد حصلت سبع مرات هدى منذ بدء
النزاع في بين الطرفين وبالتالي اعتقد انه
الامر يستحق ان نعطيه فرصه لهذه صيغه
جديده بقياده الاتحاد الافريقي مجلس الامن
والسلام بدعم من الجامعه العربيه وايجاد
والامم المتحده هنا اود ايضا ان اتحدث
قليلا عن السيد
وهو
رائعه
وموضعه الى بورت سودان وهو مبعوث المتحده
في السودان هو هذا الشخص لم يستطع ان يقوم
بعمله بشكل جيد وكان لابد من نقله الى
بورسودان ما ينبغي القيامه به حسب رايه ان
جميع الاطراف السعوديه قطر الامارات كلها
ينبغي ان يقوموا بكل ما يستطيعونه للت اي
نوع خطه نار وقف اطلاق نار مستقر دائم
والاليه لوضع الاليه لتنفيذ ذلك والنقطه
اخرى مساله التصعيد على عكس قال احد
ان الحرف في السودان بدل
لانخفض تصعدها بل زادت تصعيد لدينا حبسه
فقط في خرطوم هناك
وفي
دارفور والفلفاشر وفي الشمال دارفور وفي
العبيد انها الحرب تنتشر والى ضفت كل ذلك
فان ابعاد الحرب في السودان بدات تغير
الوانها فما لدينا الان اصبح هو
عرقنه النزاع هاي العنصر العنقري العرقي
القبائل بدا ياخذ بنظر الاعتبار انظروا ما
يحصل في دارفور احد الساده اقترح ان الشعب
الدرفور ينبغي ان يرفعوا سلاحهم
ويقاتل من اجل حقوقهم وهو ايضا
اماكن اخرى اذا اخشى ان الواقع مر والواقع
هو ليس ما نتمناه والواقع هو
الحقيقه المحزنه هي ان الحرب تتصاعد
وتنتشر
وتاخذ بعدا عرقيا
وبالتالي ان نحتاج المزيد من التدخل بواس
شكل واسع
للسيطره على الوضع وان الضيفين
العفوا الجنرلين
جرت محاوله الهدنه بينهما سبعه مرات وكل
ما يدوم الاخر عادهم احترامها سبعه مرات
يا دكتور عبد الفتاح محمد الان تقريبا
نشهد تهاوي تدريجي لكل فرص التسويه من
تعليق محادثات جدا بعد انسحاب الجيش من
هذه العقوبات وكان في النهايه الكل عليهم
الان انتظار ان يحسم احد الطرفين المعركه
او ان تستمر لفتره طويله ما توقعاتك
الذي يظهر ان الجيش لديه الامكانيه كي
يقوم بالحسم واذا يعني بتكلفه باهظه جدا
تكلفه باهظه جدا وهذا هو الخطير يعني
بمعنى تكلفه باهظه على صعيد المدنيين
السيناريو الاخر الذي هو يمكن ان يكون انه
قوه الدعم السريع ان تتحرك الى الاقليم
الذي انطلقت منه اقليم دارفور ونشهد
حرب ونزاع مثل الذي كان سابقا من 2003 الى
2009 بين المركز والطرف قد يكون هذا ايضا
من السيناريوهات موجوده السيناريو الاسوا
هو الذي نعيشه الان وهو هذه الحرب
المفتوحه والتي تتوقف فيها كل المحاولات
كل الجهود الهدن وغيرها وهي طبعا ماساويه
وكارثيه على الشعب السوداني وعلى
الانسان السوداني بشكل عام لانها تدمر
رصيده من التنميه وتدمر فرصه في التنميه
وهذا هو الخطير الذي لا نريده ان يحدث
وان يعود
السودانيون او الجنرالان الى الى وعيهما
وان يبحثوا عن مخرج لان التفكير الذي يقول
على انه يمكن ان ان الحسم العسكري ينهي
الامر قد ياتي ايضا الحسم العسكري بنتيجه
سيئه جدا وهي ان الفسيفساء السودانيه التي
فيها عرقيات وقبائل كما اشار الدكتور
هائله يمكن ايضا ان يحدث بينها صراعات
فندخل في
سيناريو خط ير جدا على مستقبل السودان في
نهايه البرنامج وبشكل سريع جدا لو سمحتم
باسلوب برقي دكتور اسامه عيدروس ثم
الدكتور هيلو وانهي في النهايه بالاستديو
مع الفتح ما الذي تتوقعه الان بعد كل ما
استعرضناه
السيناريو الاول ان يتحرك الاطراف
لهدنه حقيقيه يكون فيها اليه حقيقيه لخروج
الدعم السريع من الخرطوم الى معسكر خارجي
السيناريو الثاني ان يتم حسم المعركه
عسكريا بواسطه القوات المسلحه وهي قادره
على ذلك اما سيناريوهات هذه الحرب هي حرب
الخرطوم اي سيناريو لخروج الدعم السريع من
الخرطوم ليبدا حرب اخرى فهذا لن يحدث لان
الدعم السريع ليس له حاضنه اجتماعيه وليس
هو حركه سياسيه ولا حركه مطلبيه دكتور
هيلوا باختصار رجاء
شكرا
شكرا السيد محمد قدر كلامك ملاحظتي انها
كميلي علينا ان نبذه الخساره جهدنا لوضع
الضغوط على الطرفين اقتصاديه ودبلوماسيه
والسياسيه وما الى ذلك على الطرفين بحيث
يتوقفان عن القتال
وينفذان وقف اطلاق نار مستقر والعوده الى
ماء المفاوضات وضع اليه متابعه مراقبه
وهذا تخفيف التصعيد وايضا ايقاف عرقنه هذا
النزاع وحمايه المدنيين والنساء والرجال
والضعفاء والفقراء
وايضا تقديم طرق مفتوحه للمساعدات
الانسانيه الذي هو احسن اسوا جزء في الناس
يموتون من الجوع والاطفال يشكونا من سوء
التغذيه وبالتالي على الجانبين الجانبين
الجانبان يقولان
وبالتالي اذا كان ص عليه ما يتوقفان عن
القتال من اجل السودان اذا يضعوا مصلحه
السودان امام مصلحته
محمد انك ما يقوله الان دكتور هايلو نردده
جميعا ولكن عمليا لا شيء من هذا ينجز اذا
عدنا الى ما قاله السيد عيدروس بالاساس هي
معركه الخرطوم وهل يمكن ان تصبح فعلا
معركه نهائيه اذا خرج اغلب سكان الخرطوم
يعني اذا اذا خرج الجميع في ضوء ما يجري
الان فقد تصبح الارضيه مواطيه بين قوسين
لمعركه تحسم فيها الامور بشكل نهائي وربما
هذا هو السيناريو الاغلب السيناريو الاقوى
ان الجيش يقوم بحسم المعركه في الخرطوم
باعتبار ان التركيز على الخرطوم نعم هناك
مناوشات في دارفور وسمعنا بها وربما تسليح
لمقترح لتسليح بعض
القبائل الموجوده في بعض المناطق في
دارفور لكن خيار الحسم العسكري قد يتوجه
اليه الجيش حتى يحل هذه المشكله رغم
التكلفه كما ذكرت الباهظه بالنسبه للارواح
والمدنيين حتى لو خرج الناس من الخرطوم
سيبقى هناك يعني اهداف مدنيه ستبقى مصالح
تتضرر حقيقه اذا استخدم الجيش القوه
المميته ولكن هذه القوه المميته اللهم على
طريقه بشار الاسد يعني قصف منهجي بالطيران
وبالبراميل بشكل نهائي وان لم من الصعب ان
تحسم وهذا يحدث الان وهذا يحدث الخرطوم او
اجزاء من الخرطوم تقصف
في ملاحقه الخصم اللي هو قوه التدخل
السريع ولكن ايضا ربما الذي يفهم من تعليق
المفاوضات من طرف الجيش انه مما رشح من
تقارير ان قوه الدعم السريع لم تلتزم
الهدنه لانها قد تكون مفككه قد تكون
موجوده في جزر متباعده عن بعضها البعض لا
يوجد
يعني القياده والسيطره التي هي دائما في
تكون موجوده في الجيوش وهو ليس جيش نظامي
فربما هذا التفكك جعل الجيش يفكر
باقتراب ساعه الحسم ولكن هل هل يمكن ان
نصل الى سيناريو مرعب حقيقه لانه هذا
التعليق لمحادثات جده عبر بيان رسمي وكان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده نفض ايديهما
من الوضع السوداني مع عقوبات فبالتالي
يصبح لا شيء بالامكان القيام به سوى
المعارك حتى النهايه وهذا ايضا جانب خطير
في هذا السيناريو وفي هذه التداعيات التي
ذكرتها العقوبات وتعليق من طرف الوسطاء
والخطيره ايضا انه انه ان لا تكون هناك
مبادرات اخرى مبادرات جديده وبالتالي على
المجتمع الاقليمي وكذلك المجتمع الدولي
الا يترك السودان وحده حتى لا تتطور
الماساه الى ما هو اكثر سوءا شكرا جزيلا
لك الدكتور عبد الفتاح محمد على حضورك هنا
الاستوديو شكرا دكتور اسامه عيدروس وشكرا
دكتور بروك هايلو بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان الله
[موسيقى]